Daniel Calvisi, Script Doctor, Writing
Coach and Author: Most writers now are
making it a line of dialogue in which
a character directly states the theme
okay like the second Wonder Woman
movie there's that opening sequence…
Film Courage: How is Story Maps [STORY
MAPS: How to Write a GREAT Screenplay book
by Dan Calvisi] different from other methods
that are out there, say like Save The Cat.
Dan: Save The Cat I have a lot of problems with
I think it did a really good job at the time it
came out of making beat sheets and dramatic
elements in a screenplay more accessible to
newer writers but I don't agree with a
lot of Blake Snyder's categorizations I
think that his method the original Blake
Snyder beat sheet was designed for his
genre which is family comedy commercial family
comedies or high concept high concept comedies
like he used Miss Congeniality as one of his
pure examples in the book and it was a great
example and it's it's good screenwriting it's
a high concept fun movie but it does I don't
think his method applies to every genre whereas I
think my story map is general enough that it can
apply to any genre and in my books I do break
down movies of all genres and then now with TV
shows of all genres with Save The Cat the beat
sheet specifically there are beats in there that
I just don't think are beats okay so it opens
with opening image while an opening image isn't
a beat it's just that first description first
thing you're looking at when you start a script
and so he was saying that opening image is so
important that we're going to put it in this
10B beat sheet well I can tell you from being
a reader you forget about the first thing the
first description on page one by the time you're
halfway down page one okay the thing that you're
looking for is is what is this compelling story
what is the drama what who is the main character
and what's going to suck me in and if you can
do it with an opening image that's great but
that's very rare and I don't think you as a writer
should kill yourself trying to think of an opening
image it's better to say that first beat is you're
opening it's that page one to ten and specifically
right off the bat one to five is really key it's
how are you starting off this story what's the
first thing we see like in Breaking Bad
it has that great Flash Forward opening
and there is an opening image in there in the
original pilot script for Breaking Bad I think
it was a pair of pants flying through the air in
the desert and then the the RV like hits the pair
of pants and keeps keeps shooting down the road
and so now we're following the RV and then we meet
Walt but see the fact that I can't remember what
that opening image is is kind of a testament to it
didn't really matter because it was a great story
and that was a great sequence so that's an example
the next one either two or three in the Blake
Snyder beat sheet is called theme stated and he
says you want to show something or have a line of
dialogue that shows the audience or reader what is
the theme of this story well the problem is that
most writers now are making it a line of dialogue
in which a character directly States the theme
okay like the second Wonder Woman movie there's
that opening sequence where the Young Wonder Woman
as a girl is going through this this like trial
obstacle course thing it's a race and she's trying
to win and she takes a detour because of factors
that happen on the race and then when she's almost
winning or maybe she wins I don't remember her
mother Robin Wright grabs her and says you cheated
you don't cheat in life Diana and that was stating
the theme and I think that that writer was like oh
we have to have theme stated on page three of this
screenplay and minute five of the movie but that's
not a beat that's just telling the audience and a
telling not showing because a lot of writers
unfortunately aren't going to show it in a
really active compelling surprising way that's
not a beat that advances the story necessarily
now if you can combine it with something
that advances the story that would be great
but you don't always need it in that position
so I tell my writers express your theme
through the actions through the Beats through
the drama of the story it should be clear to us
what this is about it doesn't have to be right
away that you can settle into that as you go on
through the pilot or the script so but it should
be clear eventually that this is what this story
is about this is what it's exploring but to say
it directly to state it I think is two on the nose
where is Sid field his teachings resonated with
you yeah I mean he was the original and I mean I
don't remember if he said show don't tell in his
book then but he probably expressed that this is a
visual medium and so you want to show us something
rather than explaining everything in dialogue
just just to play devil's advocate do you
think that at the time Syd Field wrote
his book [Screenplay: The Foundations of
Screenwriting] and then the time that Blake
Schneider wrote his book that just the audiences
were receiving content in a different mindset
I mean pro I will say prob probably movies
were tighter and shorter when Blake Snyder
put out his first book if you look at films
from like the 70s and early 80s which I
think Syd Field's book came out in like ’80 or
’81. They are looser in storytelling they're
slower and they last longer so they act one of a
movie in the 70s might be more like 40 45 minutes
but by the time you get to the 90s it's almost
always 30 minutes around 30 minutes and there
are a lot of classic movies that also have that
structure like Sunset Boulevard which I break
down in my book that's one of the reasons I was
blown away by it because I watched it for the
first time as an adult and it's like exactly
100 minutes it's exactly in modern structure
and story map structure so I thought that was
really cool I know a lot of people say they've
seen the “Save The Cat-eization” of movies over
time that they they're just like okay that's
theme stated and that's Dark Night of the soul
and you can just go down the go down the list
I don't I think that's probably a little bit true
that Hollywood maybe follows it a little bit too
much but that's true I think that's true of cliche
storytelling in general there's a way to hit this
Blake Snyder beat sheet in great surprising
compelling ways like we've talked about just
as there are in my beat sheet for story Maps what
is a story map a story map is by a very powerful
tool that I developed from being a reader and a
writer and studying lots of classic movies and
television shows because I have different story
map templates for TV and for film and basically
it's a very powerful outline that breaks down the
foundational elements of your story which I call
the basic story map and those are those basic
really important things your protagonists their
external and internal goal the theme the central
dramatic question to the story which is kind of
like the main engine the obstacles standing
in their way and you have to really have that
stuff before you go to the beat sheet which is
your signpost beats the markers in the story
and for example I give them names like opening and
citing incident strong movement forward event and
turn at the end of act one and it's split into Act
One Act Two A Act Two B Act three with TV one hour
TV is usually teaser plus 4X or teaser plus 5x and
then half hour TV is usually teaser or cold open
plus 3x and so I break it down very specifically
into page ranges you don't have to hit a specific
page point but it should generally be in that in
that range because that is the industry standard
and I learned this from studying professional
screenplays for both film and TV and I saw what
do the pros do what is it that is bought and sold
what establishes a pro writer versus an amateur
and they do use this basic structure which I call
the story map how is the story map different from
everything else that's out there well I think
my categories and categorization is different
than other methods I think it's more specific I
think it's more based on professional work and
successful work in both the movies and television
I think I've probably analyzed more films and TV
than a lot of authors of other books I mean I
don't know for sure but I know I've spent a lot
of time on my method and I developed a lot of it
while I was on the job working as a professional
reader for studios and production companies so I
know that it also has an industry standard element
to it and a professional element to it but as
far as the the categorizations like in my beat
sheet I think I go into more detail in describing
them so that there's more guidance for the writer
give a story map that you can show
us from a popular movie in your book
yeah my original book Story Maps which
is how to write a great screenplay it's
about movies about features there's a lot
of great movies that I break down in here
As Good As It Gets is one that I really like
it's a romantic dramedy there's a lot of
comedy there's a lot of drama and it pretty much
follows the story map really well it's a little
bit longer of a film but I believe the first act
is definitely around 30 minutes which is pretty
standard even with longer films the first stack
tends to be about half an hour it's just kind of
the way storytelling has evolved on screen but I
just think it's a great example of storytelling
for film really compelling protagonist he's
got a lot of quirks and misbehaviors he's his
main one is OCD he's obsessive and he has this
germaphobia and that's getting in the way of his
any relationship whether it's his friendship
with his neighbor with his gay neighbor
or his possible relationship with his waitress
Helen Hunt and so he's been pushing people away
this whole time but his true goal is to let people
in to actually develop healthy relationships is
there any way you could take us a little bit
through the story map for As Good As It Gets
I know there's a lot of moments it might be
too sure yeah there's a lot of great moments
let me refresh myself with my book here I
love the opening it establishes Jack Nicholson
as just this really cantankerous guy and
it kind of shows us everything about him
a woman a neighbor comes to his door or he walks
out his door and there's a neighbor who says it's
tulip season it's such a it's such a wonderful
day I'm going outside and and she sees him
and just glowers at him like she knows this guy
just puts the kibosh on any fun and then Melvin
Udall Jack Nicholson finds his neighbor's
dog sniffing around and he doesn't like dogs
he's a germaphobe and everything and he picks up
the dog and he stuffs them down the trash chute
and it turns out so then his neighbor comes
out which is Greg Kinnear looking for this
dog and he lies and says he hasn't seen a dog so
it's just such a great way of just showing what
a jerk this guy is then he goes back into his
apartment and we see all the OCD rituals he's
washing his hands with scalding hot water and
soap and he he turns the law he has a bunch of
locks on his door he turns them a certain number
of times and ways he has all these rituals and
those are going to tie in in the end because
when he finally achieves his arc and he gets
Helen Hunt to love him and he is selfless with his
neighbor and he's a good friend to his neighbor
he realizes he didn't lock the door so it's
a visual device that he's gotten over some of
these problem these problems and obsessions that
he had so they do it in a showing not telling way.